[Music]
the raiders look to get back to even and
grab their first win of 2022 on sunday
and the good news is arizona presents
things to exploit the matchup to watch
when the raiders offense hits the field
how often do we get darren waller
involved arizona ranked in the middle of
the pack in the nfl when it comes to
defending tight ends last year but they
let travis kelsey run wild in the opener
to the tune of eight catches 121 yards
and a score isaiah simmons is their
hybrid safety linebacker type so expect
that a lot on this day as fellow titan
zachary says yeah that waller dude is a
problem
darren is a stud obviously he's been
doing it at a high level for a couple
years now
and he's just so dynamic you see his
receiver traits come out when you watch
this film he's so explosive i got a lot
of respect for him
i hope our defense shuts them down on
sunday obviously
but i root for him a lot
unfortunately three starters will be out
of this one for vegas that already
hampered offensive line will be without
center andre james piled on to two
defenders on the back end
going back to that waller and simmons
matchup simmons was a highly touted guy
out of clemson number eight pick overall
his selling point was rushing the passer
and deleting coverage the film says
otherwise hence why waller can have a
massive day too here is simmons with
kelsey we got it one on one check him
out here
kelsey
simmons as if you didn't need to know
play the tape
or right thereof
or maybe don't play the tape but that
always goes with it too he beats him
nonetheless all you need to know moving
along to the next tape this is the guy
you're more concerned about anyway
darren waller now this snap is going to
be very quick two seconds from the
release when it comes to car's hand and
into the hands of waller but here's what
here's what's important waller over here
mike davis over here and watch how he
makes him look well i guess if that
doesn't work as well nonetheless darren
waller technology issue is always going
to be a problem daryn waller should have
a massive day against this one he is a
guy who had 74 yards in the opener and
there is an exploit matchup to have when
it comes to this game and something that
the raiders fans should be very hopeful
for when it comes to sunday now when it
comes to our pre-game coverage well it
all gets going on sunday at 8 am with
pregame live and once it gets going from
there we will have you covered on
everything raiders which brings us into
our post game live coverage which will
be from allegiant stadium as well
sunday wrap sports wrap to be particular
hear from the raiders in the aftermath
of week two plenty of other coverage as
well but pregame starts us out on sunday
anytime you